you know I think we're looking out at a
new frontier right now as far as how
anyone who's trying to express
themselves creatively or just deal in
the realm of ideas as a journalist or a
writer how are you going to find a way
to survive as an artist or a creative
person I think we're all trying to
figure that out I think the Internet is
going to provide ways for you to do that
on a smaller scale and you know what a
lot of us are hoping is that the era of
people seeing hip hop as a
get-rich-quick scheme is going to fall
by the wayside and people who really
have a deep commitment to creating art
that connects with people are going to
be able to do that more than ever on a
smaller scale I mean the you have I
think it's the seth godin theory as long
as you have 2,000 loyal fans that's
enough for you to subsist as a creative
person or anyone with the public voice
and I'm hoping that bit by bit hip hop
is going to recognize that that's the
way you can sustain yourself and I think
you know a lot of a lot of things that
the younger generation is doing that we
as older hiphopheads look down upon I
see signs of hope in someone like soulja
boy who musically aesthetically we hate
if you look at the model that he's
established for how to direct how to
connect Lee direct with your audience
completely out of the mainstream and
build a lasting relationship he's far
past being a one-hit wonder now and he's
done it without any of the pretensions
that major label rappers were offering
to the public this he doesn't have any
of that sort of gangster mythology he's
not pretending to be anything else but a
regular kid who's connecting with
regular kids out there through YouTube
and you know he's built a franchise that
doesn't show any signs of slowing down
much as we may not like the music and I
feel like that's a model that a lot of
us could look towards you know for how
to create art that you know I think
there's no reason that this generations
public enemy can't follow that soldier
boy model and connect with people and
recreate that success so I'm hoping that
uh
people who represent hip hop in all the
various little sub cultures and
communities around the world where
hip-hop is blossoming bloomed I hope we
can each see I hope we can all see how
new media gives us a chance to sustain
ourselves and get our stuff